but we begin just hours away from somber
memorials and remembrances observing the
20th anniversary of the 9 11 attacks
attacks that launched the country's
longest war not only is the taliban
still in afghanistan the terror group is
now in charge and according to the biden
administration they're cooperating with
the u.s so far so much so the biden
national security council labeled the
taliban quote business-like and
professional
meantime it has been two decades without
a conviction for the accused architect
of the attacks he and four others are
involved in pre-trial hearings this week
at guantanamo bay cuba the infamous
military prison known as gitmo a prison
that now four administrations have said
they would eventually close
it has not closed and gitmo is where
pentagon reporter lucas tomlinson is
tonight good evening lucas
good evening brett 20 years after 9 11
there has still not been a trial for
those accused of planning it including
mastermind khalid sheikh mohammed
pre-trial hearings dragging on nearly a
decade at the u.s military's death
penalty case held exclusively here in
guantanamo bay cuba fox news and
selected members of the press granted
access inside the maximum security
courtroom along with 10 family members
of 9 11 victims all sitting behind thick
reinforced glass 15 years ago ksm his
nephew and a dozen other men transferred
to gitmo from cia black sites at the
time president bush denied they were
tortured the united states does not
torture
it's against our laws and it's against
our values i have not authorized it and
i will not authorize it a former gitmo
defense attorney says these hearings
would move much faster on the mainland
holding a trial in cuba where none of
the
lawyers under the
judges the interpreters the court
personnel none of them are stationed
there former president obama pledged to
close gitmo congress blocked him at
every turn including transfers back to
the united states to stand trial born in
kuwait ksm went to a small college in
north carolina before turning to a life
of terrorism beginning in afghanistan in
court this week questions to the new
judge appointed the case with only two
years on the bench one day over the
minimum required the seventh judge is
signed here at gitmo
it costs the taxpayer 13 million dollars
a year to house each prisoner
39 remain
congressman mike waltz a special forces
officer in afghanistan before being
elected says it's worth it we still need
a capacity
to detain these folks
and detain these individuals and not put
them in the united states others doubt
these cases will ever go to trial
retired lieutenant colonel donald arias
lost his brother on 9 11. my blood
pressure goes up knowing that you know
khalid sheikh mohammed still sucks air
on planet earth
you know
this should have been disposed of years
ago
brett a few minutes ago i spoke to a
woman whose brother was killed in the
north tower he was a captain with the
fire department of new york she says she
wants to see justice done she's not
happy this these hearings are dragging
on so long she wants to see justice
served and those prisoners executed
right now there's still no trial date
set brett lucas thomason live guantanamo
bay cuba lucas thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else